[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola a todos cómo están el día de hoy
quiero platicarles una anécdota que me
ocurrió mientras hacía un voluntariado
en la comunidad de nueva esperanza cerca
de la ciudad de champotón campeche
estando allí un día platicando con la
señora que nos hospedaba en su casa nos
lanzó una pregunta a mí ya mis amigos
oigan chavos se han dado cuenta que
todas las casas que hay en esta
comunidad o la mayoría de ellas están
construidas con madera y techo de la
mina
inmediatamente continuó y nos dijo saben
por qué es eso se los voy a platicar
resulta que yo construí mi casa una vez
y vino el huracán y la tiro
entonces para mí es mucho más fácil
construirla de madera dejar que venga el
huracán y la tire y después volverla a
levantar es mucho más barato para mí
ese pequeño comentario que ocurrió hace
un poco menos de cinco años me hizo
tomar muchísima sensibilidad sobre la
importancia que tiene una casa para un
ser humano pero a mayor escala también
la infraestructura que que tenemos en
nuestras ciudades en nuestro país y en
nuestro planeta
piénsalo un poquito el agua con la que
te bañas el agua que probablemente bebes
directamente del grifo después de
pasarla por un filtro el agua con la que
la vas tu ropa tuvo que venir de algún
lado y llegó a tu casa gracias a que hay
una red muy compleja allá afuera bajo la
tierra que se encarga de que el agua se
las arregle para poder llegar a la llave
de tu casa de igual manera la energía
que traes en tus dispositivos móviles en
tu celular en tu laptop el aire
acondicionado que enciendes cuando
tienes calor el calefactor que enciendes
cuando tienes frío todo ello requiere
energía también que debió provenir de
algún lado y viene de un sistema muy
complejo que está allá afuera y que si
tú sales a tu casa lo puedes ver qué
pasa por los posts y si no lo ves pues
es porque pasa por debajo de la tierra
también
para llegar aquí al out lab seguramente
tuviste que pasar por periférico
ecológico la recta cholula camino real a
lo mejor toma hasta alguna autopista en
el mejor de los casos a lo mejor tomaste
un vuelo y la infraestructura estuvo ahí
todo el tiempo y sobre las carreteras
me gusta mucho siempre hacer este
comentario una carretera es mucho más
que una simple franja cubierta de
asfalto una carretera es una conexión
entre una familia que trabaja y sus
hijos que lo están esperando en casa
entre una familia que está ansiosa por
vivir una nueva experiencia en el viaje
que tienen planeando entonces la
importancia de la infraestructura es
vital para nosotros y por eso sostengo
que la importancia de la infraestructura
y más aún de la infraestructura
resiliente como lo veremos adelante
radica en que nos permite construir
ciudades y sociedades inquebrantables
un poquito de historia nuestra
infraestructura está expuesta a
muchísimos fenómenos esta clasificación
viene de la ley general de protección
civil está bueno aquí omitir los
fenómenos astronómicos que también están
allí incluidos pero me ocupe de los que
no de los que ocurren afuera del espacio
sino aquí dentro de la tierra y estos
dos primeros creo que son los que
afectan directamente a nuestra
infraestructura y quizá estos tres
últimos le afecten más de manera
indirecta y en algunos casos quizás muy
específicos también de manera directa
los fenómenos geológicos por ejemplo
hablábamos por la mañana sobre los
sismos que ocurrieron en 2017 pero
también tenemos algunas experiencias no
solamente en méxico sino en todo el
mundo aquí en pueblo en 1999 uno hubo
uno muy fuerte el de 1985 que quizá
algunos de ustedes recuerden el de 1957
en fin los ejemplos son muchísimos
también otros de los fenómenos
geológicos que tenemos son los volcanes
que están ahí todo el tiempo y nosotros
estamos a la expectativa de lo que
ocurra con ellos y ya ha habido muchas
erupciones tan sólo el año pasado
tuvimos el ejemplo del vol
y la huella en hawai el volcán de fuego
en guatemala y mientras tanto nosotros
aquí en puebla también estamos a la
expectativa de lo que suceda con el
volcán popocatépetl también hay en este
punto el fallo porque se desgaja en los
cerros por ejemplo recientemente hubo el
fallo de un dique en brásil que contenía
aguas residuales provenientes de una
mina en fin ahí están los fenómenos
geológicos y nos afectan afectan a
nuestra infraestructura los fenómenos
hidrometeorológicos creo que tienen un
acento importante porque sus sentencias
sus intensidades se han visto
amplificada por los efectos del cambio
climático aquí tenemos los huracanes
como el huracán huila que pegó
recientemente en la costa de nayarit y
en sinaloa pero también tenemos ejemplos
internacionales como el huracán katrina
en 2005 que devastó la ciudad de nueva
orleans y muchos otros tenemos también
sequías cada vez más prolongadas como la
que ocurre en francia en la primera
década de los años 2000
tenemos tormentas cada vez más severas
en este país quizás no tanto pero en
otros países si tenemos la incidencia de
tornados en fin ahí están todo el tiempo
esos fenómenos y están siempre tienen el
potencial de afectarnos a nuestra
infraestructura y por consecuencia a
nosotros en tercer lugar y con estos me
voy a ir un poquito más rápido los
teléfonos químicos y los tecnológicos se
refieren por ejemplo explosiones aquí en
méxico tuvimos un ejemplo muy reciente
se refieren a radiaciones como la que
hubo en fukushima en 2011 y en chernóbil
en 1986
se refiere también a esta clasificación
entran también los derrames de
sustancias peligrosas las fugas en fin
muchos fenómenos que entran esta
clasificación los sanitarios y los
ecológicos aquí quizá los más vigentes
pues sean de los que hablan de los que
escuchamos todo el tiempo la
contaminación del aire la contaminación
del agua la contaminación del suelo pero
también hay otros que podrían afectar a
nuestra infraestructura de manera
indirecta por ejemplo las epidemias y
las plagas podrían poner en jaque la
capacidad de los hospitales y de las
clínicas que hay en el país o en el
mundo y finalmente los socios
organizativos estos fenómenos socio
organizativos son aquellos que son
generados por la actividad humana y aquí
entran tanto los accidentes como los que
se hacen de manera intencional los que
se hacen de manera intencional pues
desde luego son el terrorismo el
sabotaje
y los accidentes de tránsito 2 los que
ocurren en el espacio en los aeropuertos
en el espacio marino todos ellos también
entran dentro de esta clasificación
entonces qué está ocurriendo que nuestra
infraestructura está expuesta a todo
este tipo de fenómenos y en ese sentido
nuestra infraestructura debería ser más
resiliente porque la historia nos ha
enseñado que es vulnerable y que por
consecuencia también nosotros somos
vulnerables
en ese sentido la organización de las
naciones unidas estableció 17 objetivos
para el desarrollo sostenible los
empezaron a trabajar en 2002 y los
publicaron en 2015 y entraron en vigor a
partir de 2016 el noveno de ellos habla
de industria innovación e
infraestructura y el primer target de
este objetivo habla del desarrollo de
infraestructura resiliente entre otras
cosas y aquí está subrayado y ahora lo
subrayó verbalmente a continuación vamos
a platicar de de qué es eso para empezar
qué es eso de la infraestructura
resiliente y por qué es tan importante
bien aquí tenemos la palabra resiliencia
y alrededor de ella giran tres aspectos
que deben de tener los sistemas de
infraestructura para para poder ser
resilientes y poder mantener las
condiciones de servicio
y antes de ello pues voy a definir qué
es eso de infrestructura resiliente
porque he estado mencionando mucho pero
no se los he dicho verdad entonces
pregunten me que es la infraestructura
resiliente
bueno la infraestructura resiliente es
aquella infraestructura que es capaz de
mantener las condiciones de servicio
para los usuarios independientemente de
las perturbaciones que que pueda tener
por la presencia de algún fenómeno
específico como los que necesitamos hace
rato en este momento voy a anunciar los
tres aspectos que debe de tener la
infraestructura resiliente el primero es
la robustez y aquí es más fácil
explicarlo con un ejemplo imagínate un
hospital que está en una zona sísmica y
que de pronto empieza a temblar y hay
desde luego cirugías en proceso en ese
momento el edificio tiene que ser las
columnas del edificio las trabes tienen
que ser lo suficientemente grandota lo
suficientemente robustas para poder
soportar
el movimiento por consecuencia del sismo
pero además el poder proteger a quienes
están adentro del edificio en ese
momento y sobre todo los que están más
vulnerables entonces ese es un ejemplo
de robustez otro ejemplo podría ser una
presa por ejemplo una presa no es más
que una pared grandota que contiene un
volumen de de agua de este lado para que
los de este lado no se inunden una presa
de control de inundaciones
la presa debe ser lo suficientemente
alta lo suficientemente robusta para
poder contener la cantidad de agua de
una tormenta extraordinaria eso es la
robustez en la infraestructura la
redundancia es más fácil ejemplificar la
en las carreteras muchas ocasiones
seguramente has tenido alguna
alguna experiencia este tipo en alguna
vía de comunicación
tuviste que esperar mucho tiempo porque
hubo a lo mejor un accidente de tránsito
o porque a lo mejor hubo el
deslizamiento de un cerro que estaba ahí
cerca oa lo mejor hubo un sismo y la
carretera tuvo problemas en fin pudo
haber muchos muchos muchos fenómenos que
la afectaran pero de qué se trata la
redundancia en las redundancias ok tú
querías ir del punto a al punto b y hay
desde luego esta principal vía de
comunicación pero no te preocupes si
esta falla tú tienes otra por la cual
puedes llegar a lo mejor es más larga a
lo mejor tiene más curvas pero mientras
la principal no funcione está si lo
puede hacer otro ejemplo de redundancia
podría ser el sistema cutzamala el
sistema cutzamala abastece en un
porcentaje importante alrededor del 35
por ciento de agua potable a la ciudad
de mexico y cómo funciona rápidamente el
sistema cutzamala
el sistema cutzamala no es más que un
tubo bueno un par de tubos en realidad
que bombean agua del río lerma y del río
cutzamala hacia la ciudad de mexico en
una altura más o menos de un kilómetro
en promedio y entonces cuando lo
construyeron obviamente solamente había
un tubo pero ese tubo pues podía fallar
en algún momento y si fallaba se tenía
que interrumpir el suministro para la
ciudad de mexico que hicieron entonces
pues construyeron otro tubo paralelo a
ese para que si uno de los dos falla
además de para aumentar la capacidad
hacerlo más robusto también en caso de
que uno de los dos fallara el otro
pudiera cubrir la demanda del de al lado
entonces ese es un ejemplo de
redundancia finalmente tenemos la
respuesta y la respuesta no es más que
la capacidad que tiene la
infraestructura de concentrar todos sus
recursos materiales financieros y
humanos para poder recuperarse
inmediatamente después del efecto de un
fenómeno por ejemplo regreso al ejemplo
del sistema cutzamala apenas tuvieron
esos cuates una bronca con una pieza que
fue la famosa k invertida seguramente lo
leyeron o lo escucharon
qué pasó pues para no entrar en detalles
pusieron mal la pieza y entonces cuando
volvieron a activar las bombas la pieza
se desplazó y pues corrió el peligro de
perderse ahí entonces qué hicieron estos
cuates concentraron todos sus recursos
para poder solucionar rápidamente la
bronca y poder salir adelante de ese
problema y mientras tanto mientras tan
concentrando esos recursos mandaron un
sistema de pipas a abastecer a las
ciudades que se habían quedado sin agua
por consecuencia de este problema
entonces estos son los tres aspectos que
debe de tener la infraestructura
resiliente en general ahora bien
recapitulando hablamos un poquito de la
importancia que tiene la infraestructura
para nosotros vemos que hay un marco
establecido por la organización de las
naciones unidas para trabajar en esa
dirección y tercero anunciamos cuáles
son los tres aspectos de la resiliencia
en la infraestructura ahora bien me voy
a regresar a esta diapositiva y los
invito a que aquí echemos un vistazo
aquí a esta parte que no está subrayada
pero que debería estarlo porque creo que
es importantísima y aquí es donde me voy
a regresar a la anécdota de doñana y su
casa en campeche
aquí dice que el enfoque del desarrollo
de la infraestructura debe de ser
también con un acceso equitativo para
todos
y qué significa eso entonces y es aquí
donde voy a concluir y contarles lo que
yo creo que es el desafío para la
ingeniería en general para la ingeniería
civil en particular y para las
disciplinas involucradas en el
desarrollo de infraestructura
de qué se trata
para poder hacer más accesible la
infraestructura y la infraestructura
resiliente en particular hacia las
poblaciones sobre todo las que están
alejadas de los grandes centros urbanos
se requiere que lo sea ya se haga mucho
más investigación en nuevas tecnologías
para los materiales de construcción
hacerlos más eficientes hacerlos buscar
la manera de que sean menos costosos
para la gente que sean más accesibles
para ellos de igual manera implementar
instrumentos para el ordenamiento
territorial implementar políticas
públicas que estén orientadas hacia el
asia facilitar el que la gente pueda
tener infraestructura de calidad e
infraestructura resiliente en particular
yo creo
voy a trabajar en ello
que si la ingeniería
fue capaz de hacer cosas tan grandes
obras de ingeniería
tan ambiciosas quizá en su momento
también es capaz de cubrir con este reto
y aquí es donde se introduce otro
concepto que es el de infraestructura
sostenible
me quedan poco menos de tres minutos
entonces eso no voy a detallar mucho en
la infraestructura sostenible en el 2020
cuando me inviten pues con mucho gusto
vengo y platicamos sobre eso pero a
grandes rasgos la infraestructura
sostenible se trata de mantener ese
balance entre el desarrollo social el
desarrollo económico
y el desarrollo sustentable en ese
sentido es donde creo que debe de ir la
ingeniería gracias por permitirme
compartir con ustedes mi experiencia les
agradezco mucho su atención mi nombre es
eduardo guevara
[Aplausos]